なんでこの人を選んだっていうこともすぐすぐわかります
社会の出家論 失敗者 問題児
非常識な人は出家の道を選ぶと
これ社会はそう思っているんです
変やと 出家するのはおかしいと
変人だとびっくりしているんです
なんであんた出家するんですかと
おかしいでしょうと 不適者は生きるために
はい これからは世間論ということを覚えておいてください
これ 仏教の話ではないんです
俗世間の勉強ができなくなる
できなくて 学校に社会に適応できなくて
仕事をする自信も勇気もなく
常識的な思考がなく いう名誉が潰れた時
病弱になった時 結婚できない
離婚されたなどがある時
神秘世界に興味を持った時
出家するんです しかし
UFOはバスで霊感は OK です
UFO に興味ある人は出家しません
霊感の連中はまあ一応
家族から追い出された時
どうにもならない時 出家をするのは常識です
こういうふうに思ってるでしょ
世界は 普通の日本でも普通の家族の人が
私はお寺に入ると思ったら
親には信じられない 何言うのかと
あなた 我々と同じく このむちゃくちゃな
もう矛盾だらけの命やってくださいと
出家なんかするもんじゃないんでしょうという立場なんです
それで世間の立場はそういうことです
あの名誉がなくなった時とか
いろいろ頭にあったんですけど
例は で ちょっとなんか変なことをして批判を受けちゃうと
さっさとこのタレントの方々はお寺に籠もるんです
お寺に籠もって 3ヶ月間ぐらいいて
のこのことまた出てくる
だから出家っていうのはそういう人々のためにあるものだと思っているんです
それで出家者の立場から見るとどうなるのかと
弱き者の逃げ場 隠れ場なんです
社会でうまくいかない
あの競争できない 俺は出家するぞ
お寺に入るぞということになるんです
社会に認められるための近道でもあります
変なことやっちゃって
法律でもおかしくちゃってね
仕事もなくなって降板されたら
どこかのお寺に隠れるんです
で そこで座禅組んだり
もう半年ぐらい経ったらまた社会に戻る
だから近道なんです いろいろひどい悪いことをしても
今あの人どこ？今あの人はもうずっとお寺に入って座禅座禅組んでるんだと
だから座禅して心は成長した方からならどうでもいいんです
真面目に座禅しているのかどうかね
それはどうでもいいんです
それ 年月だけ半年ぐらいいれば OK
合格 また社会に戻ってちょうだいと
まあ褒め称えてあげるんです
だから出家する人も 社会で成功するための近道として使っているんです
気楽に生きられる 生きられる世界だと
また出家は まあそれは主にテーラワーダ仏教の世界ではね
出家したらまあ気楽に生きていられると
変わったことに挑戦する世界
まただいたいそういう人もいますよ
あんな出家でもして あの変わったことをやってみたいんだと
いう興味の人がいる 超能力
神秘力を得て 祈祷師になれる世界
まあ修行したら 3ヶ月間ぐらい山を登ったり下りたりとかね
それから祈祷師になれます
あの祈祷しても それは幸福になるか
そんなこと誰も聞きませんよ
あの人はあの山は 3ヶ月間登った
あの山はまた 3ヶ月間登ったとか
それで十分です あるいは 1ヶ月間
毎日朝 3時に起きて森に入っていたとか
森から出ている時はもう大体もう12時ぐらいになりますよと
これが半年も続きましたよ
あるいは 1ヶ月間続きましたよと
それから祈祷すると みんなありがたく祈祷してもらうんです
罪滅ぼしを滅ぼしをして
またのこのこと社会に出てくるため
一時的に後退する世界
出家っていうのは 何か悪いことをしたら罪滅ぼしに出家になる
なってのこのこと出てくる
だから一時的な後退する場所です
断食 滝行などの苦行をして
自分に自信をつけるための世界
なんか変な苦行をしたら
なんとなく自分で私は結構もう頑張れるんだという自信をつけてもらうためにも出家する
つまらない世界から離れて
大宇宙の真理に囲まれる世界
そういう病気な人もいますよ
なんか私は大宇宙の力に囲まれているんだとかね
私の宇宙のパワーが流れてくるんだとかね
頑張ってほしいんです
みんな 社会が出家を仰ぐ
社会もアホやと思っていますよ
出家は 出家者もアホな汚い目的で出家するんですよ
社会を出家するのはバカだ
アホだ 異常者やと思っているし
出家者もこれでもう近道やと
成功するために 社会に認めるために近道やと思ってるんです
だからお互い様知ってますよ
なのに社会が出家を仰ぐんです
敗者の世界なのに 社会が一旦出家した人を批判しません
敗者が出家しますよ しかし批判しません
この世界ででも その世界ででも幸福になってほしいという親切な気持ちもあるでしょう
だから あの人はね 会社ではね
もう全くダメな人間でしたから
まあ出家でもして まあなんとか生きていればいいんじゃないということで認めるんです
これはもう社会の親切な気持ちなんです
社会人はやりたくない
やりたくはないことをやる人々だからありがたい
だから出家が社会人がやりたくないことをやっているんです
やった方がいいのに ああ
私は嫌やと思っちゃうでしょ
ありがたがるんです 例えば冬
滝行やるとかね 誰でもやりたくないでしょ
そうすると誰かが誰かがやっちゃうと拍手する
拍手するんですよ すごいすごいと
だから出家が自分がやりたくないことをやっているんだから
出家を仰ぐことになるんです
占い 祈祷 祝福 お守り 祈りをしてくれるからありがたい
俗世間でつまづいたら
何かうらばさ 裏知恵 霊
警言などを伝えてくれるんですよ
出家が すぐそういった人に
あのね あなたはね おじいさんのお墓参りしてないでしょ
あ そうなんですけど 今年
あのね あんた６年も行ってないんですよと
あ びっくりするの 本人言ったことなんですけど
人が言うと あれ ポコッと取って見事に読まれた
読まれたもんだなと ぴったし６年見てないと言われたんですからと
私 私にとってすごい面白いんですよ
漫才よりも占いなんかやってるやり取りやってみる
やってあれ見てみると
もうお腹が痛いほど面白いんです
まんまとカモにされるんです
それであのラーメンとお茶と
お線香 お墓に１週間唱えてくださいと
それで問題解決しますよと
バカがやるんですよ だからそういう風に
このいろいろ裏知恵 裏技
出家が教えてくれるんだからということで
まあ仰る仰がれます 四捨儀礼をしてくれるんですね
どんな宗教でも四捨儀礼は宗教の人々はやるんです
聖職者がやるんです 神の代表してくれるんです
あの結構変なことばっかり
ローマ法王 ローマ法王とかいるでしょ
なんか世間のこと知らないみたい
あの人は だがしかし 彼が神の代表なんです
天国の鍵が ローマ法王を持っているんです
そういうことでありがたがるんです
仰ぐんです えーと ちょっと休みましょうか
でも半分が言ってないんで
ここはあと５枚行ってから休憩にします
世間的出家の指導者 はい
今は仏教の話じゃないんです
だから私が批判したら私に怒鳴ってください
ブッダの話じゃないんです
世間の話です これで世間で異常者が異常者っていうのは悪い意味で異常者ではなくて
変な人ことを考える人がね
で 仕事 会社でうまくいかなかった人が出家する
出家したら指導を受けなくちゃいけないんですよ
出家生活の ただ頭を剃っただけではね
意味がないんだから だって出家しない人も髪の毛今剃るんだから
その方が安上がりですよ
あれ なんとかつけるよりは
で 髪の毛薄くなるともう全部丸刈りにした方がね
もう金はかかりません
はい まあそれは置いておいて
だから髪の毛剃っただけで出家ではありません
何か修行しなくちゃいけない
では 誰が指導するのかということは
宗教組織に入る人はそちらの決まりに従いますね
それはわかりやすい どこかの宗教組織で出家したら
そちらの決まりがありますから
それを守ります そちらに我他より優れたりと言いたい人が現れるので
避けてきた競争にまた巻き込まれます
本当にこのこの聖職の世界も恐ろしいんですよ
気持ち悪いんです 出家したくなります
その世界にいると そこで修行で競争するんですよ
あの人より私は優れたりということで
それで立場作ろうと思っているんです
同じこっちゃですけど
こっち社会にいたっても出家したっても
結局は 格を取ろうと で
日本だったら衣の色でいろいろランクあるでしょうに
だからなんとかして色違い上のランクに行こうとかね
やってますよ だから社会で負けちゃって
競争で一旦出家組織に入ったら
そこでまたあの醜い競争の世界があるんです
巻き込まれます 組織に入らない人は
自分勝手に決めた何かをやってます
宗教組織ではなくて 自分勝手に山に入ったら何するかというと
自分勝手なことやってます
社会でも負け犬でしょ
社会で普通の社会人で生きていられなかったんです
思考がおかしくて それで出家したでしょうに
それで一人勝手に何か決めたって
もうダメに決まってます
そんなのは すごい頭が良ければ
社会ででもうまくいくはずなんです
だから 社会的な人が出家するのは失敗したからでしょうに
それで自分勝手で修行の道を選んだら
なおさらダメな人間になるんです
昔 あるテレビである人が
あの なんか無人島かどこかで
もう社会から離れ 出家なんですよ
出家じゃないんです あるおじいさんが一人でいるんですよ
しかし 真っ裸で裸で スーッと裸で出るんです
それで有名なもうこうやって出家して離れてすごい生活してる人がいるんだと
どんどん人気が出てきて
仰がれるようになっちゃったりして
これでテレビカメラが入るんですね
テレビカメラが入ったら
本人がそれでも裸で あれやこれやでいい加減なことを言うんです
どうったことなかったんですけど
だから自分勝手で修行を決めても
もともとダメな人でしたから
それもダメになるんです
しかし 出家の修行はほとんど社会が決めるんです
この出家世界忘れていることはそれなんです
自分たちが何するべきかということは
在家社会が決めるんです
社会が自分にできないこと
憧れることなどを出家に期待する
だから社会人が自分にできないことと
自分が憧れていることを出家にあなたやりなさいと言うんです
この馬鹿どもたちは真面目にやるんです
社会が贅沢主義なので
出家は基本的に苦行主義です
日本でもそうでしょ 教えには全然関係ないんだけど
坊主ならおしんことご飯しか食べてはいけないとかね
あと 永平寺では朝はお粥とたくあん 2枚しか食べてはいけないとか
誰が決めたんで そんなことは
なんでカツ丼食べて悪いんですかね
私はあまり好きじゃないんだけど
若者でしょうに いい加減ですよ
結局は まあ昔はもうあまり食料がなかったんだからね
いろいろ節約するのはね
今でも米 1粒でも落ちたら
それを拾ってまた入れるというね
なんだあれはと私が思いたいんですよ
そこで茶碗にあるご飯を 1粒1粒全部食べて
それからお茶を入れて
それを洗ってまた飲むと
あれ 我々の文化ではすっごい気持ち悪いんです
恐ろしいことであると
やるなよと なぜかというと
仏教文化だから もうカレーとご飯食べるでしょ
だから皿にはべちゃべちゃついてますよ
それは我々は洗って普通の土に捨てるんです
どうか微生物と虫たちの餌
食べ物になりますようにと
食べる前にもお布施をする
もうカラスとか猫とか
誰か食べてほしいと 食べて終えてからも洗って飲むそうじゃないんです
手はなめません 手は洗うんです
それでご飯は未精物資の栄養になるんだと
だから信じられないんですよ
あれも仏教 これも仏教なんですけど
結局は なんだこの差はと
で とにかく基本的に苦行になってますよ
あの キリスト教の方々も
あの神父さんやら牧師さんやら
モンクという人々が結構修行するんですよ
でも何の根拠もないんで
修行するためには 聖書では一言もないんです
修行しなさいと だから神様にこの人々は逆らってますよ
聖書は神様の言葉でしょうに
言ってないんです 断食しなさいとか
あれやこれやとか 鞭で体を打って
特にシスターたちとかね
ちょっとでも欲が生まれたら体で打ったりとか
あのフィリピンでもよくやりますけどね
自分のあの なんとか十字架に打ってもらったりとかしますよ
若者は それで鞭で自分の体にピシピシと打って怪我して
そうするとすごい清らかになった気分になりますよと
そうともうもう直らないんですね
あの調子なら だから私は聞きたいのは
ああいう方々は自分たちには宗教がある
宗教には聖書がある 聖書が自分たちのガイドブックでしょうに
なんで聖書に一言葉も書いてないものをやってますかね
受難はイエス様一人で十分だと明確にこっきりと書いてますよ
苦しみの私だけで十分ですと
君たちはただで助けてあげますと
ただ乗りで ただ乗りっていうのは私の冗談的な言葉ですけど
一応意味はその意味なんです
なのに で 私は聞きたい
なんでカトリックの人々は結婚しないんですかね
結婚しないで性的なおかしいことをやって
裁判かけるわ もう何億も損害賠償というか
するわ それでもごまかすわ
いや アフリカとかいろんな国々の人々はもう結婚認めなさいよと言ってるのに
ダメというんです 結婚はダメ
性的犯罪はそれはOK
なんだこれ 性的犯罪は OK
裏で女作るのも OK 裏で子供作って面倒見ないのは OK
しかし 届け出して結婚するなよと
だから私にとっては本当にわからない
私は本人たちにも聞いたことありますよ
聞く時はもういい加減な説明
だってイエス様はこう苦しんだでしょうとかね
それで肉魚食べない日があったりとかね
ご飯食べない日があったりとかね
そういう余計にどうでもいいお祭り
強引に作ったりして だからああいうことは神様の言葉じゃないんです
社会の言葉なんです よく覚えておいてください
社会がそれがありがたがるんです
誰とも会うことをしないで
隠れて 人が来たら小さな窓を開けて
窓から何の用ですかと
何々人に会いたい 会いませんよ
はい カチッとドア そういう風に隠れていることなんか
みんななんてありがたい神父様たちでしょうかとかね
社会が褒めるんです そこでそこをうろうろ回ったりして
あの線香じゃなくて あの香を称えたりして
祝福してもらいます そういうことで
出家の師匠が指導者がきっちりだらしない社会なんです
贅沢するために 欲に溺れるために出家することは
社会は認めませんよ 非難する
はい そういうわけで このいい加減な出家システムが世の中でどんな宗教にもあります
宗教がなくても出家できます
出家したら 自分が逃げた
嫌で逃げた社会は先生にして
その言う通りにやります
だったら社会人になって言う通りにやった方がもっとマシなんですけど
真面目に仕事をするとか
社会人というと 社会人にはこう言うんです
仕事をしなさい 家族を養いなさい
ということを言ってるでしょ
それやればあまり問題ないのに
お前ら言うことを聞きたくないと逃げて出家するんですよ
あなた方言うことは聞きたくないと
逃げたら その人々の言うことを聞いているんです
結局は 苦行したり おかしいでしょ？世界一般的に修行イコール苦行でしょ
何ですか それは それは社会は贅沢主義だからなんです
贅沢できるかできないか問題がないんです
みんな贅沢したいんです
できるのは一部の人々だけですけど
社会はみんな贅沢したいんです
だから出家に汝苦行をしなさいと言うんです
やるんです はい 出家が社会の生き方を見て
それと違ったことを修行だとするんです
それで出家の立場 出家も社会人がやることと違ったことをやればいいやと思っているんです
社会人に認められること
尊敬されることをしたがるんです
それから社会人が認めること
尊敬することを選んでやるんです
社会の目を気にするんです
出家したいとは ですから
俗世間が出家の指導者になるんです
精神的に優れる見込みはゼロです
そういうわけだから だって社会人が別に精神的に優れてるわけじゃないでしょうに
毎日の喜びで生きているだけでしょうに
その人々から教えてもらったっても
自分が精神的に優れたんだと
ありえないんです 社会と変わった生き方するだけです
基準は社会なので 世間の道対出家の道という 2つが現れますが
世間の道 それに対立して出家の道と 2つありますよ
ありますが 俗世間的な次元は超えられないんです
どちらでも 昔からこの調子
これちゃうと はい じゃあここら辺で休憩いたします
はい これから言うのは
今まで私は現代人がおかしいとずっと言っていたんですけど
これは昔も同じなんです
あの出家っていうのは変だと思っていたんです
これは真面目に82の
経典ですね ラッタパーラスッタというんです
クルクニトゥッラコッティタというバラモンの村にお釈迦様が入ります
その村の裕福な家庭の一人息子であるラッタパーラが説法を聞いて出家を祈願する
ものすごい金持ちの家なんです
しかし 一人息子 お釈迦様の説法を聞いて出家したくなっちゃったんです
1週間のファーストをやって
やっと親の許可を得て出家するんです
でこれ経典長く書いてますよ
もう親は絶対出家認めたくないんですね
一人息子だから 子供一人しかいない
ものすごい財産があって
だからものすごい反対してね
反対したら この子はもうそれだったら私は死にますと
出家認めないならばということで座り込んだんですね
いろいろ言っていてももう聞かなかったんです
それで友達にも頼んで
なんとかしてこの気持ち変えてくださいと言ったら
友達も話してみたら やっぱり本人は本気なんですね
死ぬつもりなんです 出家するか死ぬかと
そうすると友達が親に言ったんですよ
この人はもう本気ですよと
我々に我々が言ったっても話聞かないんだと
そのまま放っておくと
あなた方の子供は死にますよと
だから 生きている子供が欲しいか死んで欲しいかと
あなた方決めてくださいと
で 子供が生きて欲しいければ出家許可せなくちゃいけないんですね
そうすると許可したんですね
彼が比丘になって半年後
お釈迦様が 斎場に入る
そこでラッタパーラ比丘が最終解脱に達する
斎場に入ってから サーヴェッティに入ってから
そこで修行して大阿羅漢になります
お釈迦様の許可を得て
親に顔を見せるためにクル国に入り
コーラビ王の園に泊まります
そこでもう悟りに達しましたし
出家した目的に達しましたし
もうやることがないし
あれほど自分のことを可愛がって育てた親に
じゃあ自分が元気で目的に達して一人前になったということを顔を見せたかったんです
だから でもお釈迦様はダメと言ったら行かないんですからね
ちょっと危険な存在だからね
この人は ものすごい金持ちで
ものすごい強引に出家したんだから
家に戻ったらどうなるかわからない
で とにかく王様の園に泊まるんですね
あのストーリーはカットします
皆様 どうしても全部経典読みたければ
すごい読みやすい経典で読んでみてください
王は園に遊びに行きたく
家来に準備を頼む 家来は準備をして
ラッタパーラ長老が見て王に報告するんです
王様が公園に行きたかったんです
王様が来るんだから 全部準備しなさいと
みんな準備はしたんですけど
お坊さん一人いるんですね
見たら これはこの同じ国のラッタパーラお坊さんですね
若いんですけど 言ったらお釈迦様
王様にそれを報告するんです
王様がよく褒めていた
気になっていたラッタパーラ長老がこの町に入っているので
お会いすることができるのではないかと報告するんです
王様の気に入りなんですね
この若者は すごい人やとか
なんとかとかね よく頑張りましたとかね
よくももう死ぬ覚悟で断食した
もうよく褒めていたみたいですね
それでそっちをそのラッタパーラのこと
王様が言ってるし もう戻ってきたんですから会えますよと
大変喜んだ王は遊びをやめてラッタパーラ長老と対話することにするんです
じゃ 今日は遊びはやめます
今日は真面目な話をしますと
ラッタパーラ長老と決めたんです
王様が世間常識ではどのような目的で人は出家するのだと説明して質問するんです
なぜ人は出家するのかと王様は教えてあげるんです
教えてあげて質問するんです
4つの災難 ん？あの あの単語は勝手に決めたんであって
日本のテキストは別な単語あるかもしれません
1 老衰災難 ある人は老衰になって
再婚の再起生活も収入を得ることもできなくなって
楽に老後を過ごす目的で出家する
字が間違って出家するんです
この辺でちょっと説明します
老衰だから財産を守ることもできないし
新しい財産を作ることもできないし
管理もできない これではもう大変です
それで出家するんだと
それはパーリ語でジャラーパーリジュンニャンと言うんです
しかし あなたは体力に溢れている
髪も黒い若者である なぜあなたは出家したのですか？おかしいでしょうと
あんた老衰じゃないでしょうと
もう二十歳ですね 二十歳
二十代 こんな元気なあなたね
なんで出家したんですかと
人は出家しませんよと
老衰にならない限りは
二番目 病弱災難 病に陥って体力がなくなって在家生活ができなくなった人は
その理由で出家するが
健康そのもののあなたはなぜ出家したのですか？パーリ語でビャーディパーリジュンニャンと言うんです
それから何か不治の病に陥る
もう在家生活できない
財産の管理できない そういう人は全部財産を置いておいて出家すると
というあなた何なのかと
もう健康そのものでしょう
ラッタパーラが なんであんた出家したんですかと
三番目 倒産災難 人は富豪でいたのに倒産してしまいます
新たに富を得ることができなくなって出家することになる
突然倒産する もうどうにもならん
何にもできない そうすると出家すると
しかし 大富豪であったあなたはなぜ出家したんですかと
家にあり余るほど財産があるんです
ついでにラッタパーラ長老の私はカットしたエピソードも言います
ラッタパーラ長老が国に入って
朝自分の家に行ったんです
托鉢に もう家出たんだから家の中に入らなかったんです
托鉢に行ったら この夫婦親がラッタパーラさんが出て行ったその日から出家は大嫌いで
もう全く誰にも家に入ることはできない
宗教まで大嫌いで もうものすごい反対
息子を盗まれたと だからラッタパーラ長老が家の玄関の前ででっかい家だからね
待っていても誰もご飯ひとさじはくれません
そうすると ずっと待っていると
ある召使の女の人が なんて言いますか
この あの 米の粉ではなく
なんとかこう米の粉で何かパンみたいなものを作るんです
焼くものではなくて 蒸すん
蒸して作るもの それは１２日経つと腐るんです
それでたくさんそういうものを一応作って
腐ったものがあって これは外へ出す
捨てるそうと思って外へ出ていくんです
外へ出ていったら ラッタバー長老はその人のことを知ってますからね
でお姉ちゃん これ何するに？何のために持っていくんですかと聞いたら
あっ これはもうもう腐ってね
食べられないんだから捨てますと
言ったら ラッタバー長老が
もしあなたはそれ捨てるならば
1個ぐらいこの鉢に入れてくださいと
まあどうせゴミに捨てるんだから
まあいいよと  1個あげたんです
腐ったもの ラッタバー長老はそこら辺に座ってそれを食べたんです
と体見たら このメスカイガの女の人はびっくりしちゃって
怖くなっちゃって えっ？これお茶ではないかと
言ったら まあ一応そうなんですけど
言ったら大騒ぎして家に入って
なんてことか もう大変やと
もうそこが帰っているんだと
ったら親が喜んじゃって
本当かと お前言うこと本当だったら
お前もう奴隷からもう解放してあげるぞと言って外へ出てみたら
すごく腐ってて臭ってる
あのパンを食べてるんですね
そうか 親に我慢できないことなんですよ
ものすごい金持ちだから
あんた何いうこと？やんのことするんですかと
なんで自分の家なのに入れませんですかと
そんなこと早く捨てなさいと
家に入ってもご飯食べましょうと言ったら
いい 今日の食事はありましたからと
と言って 女郎がもう出て帰りますと言ったら
そんなこと言わないで
家に帰ってご飯食べなさいと言ったら
もう明日ということになった
では明日来なと で 明日ご飯食べに行ったんですね
食事に行ったら 夜 家にある財産
あれやこれや全部持ってきて
いろんなところで置いて
奥さんたちも何人かがいたんです
一人二人じゃないんです
もしかするとあれで出家することに決めたかもしれません
一人でも多すぎですか
で みんなにお前らもね
もうありったけのおしゃれをして
ものすごいべっぴんさんでもう
ください 用意しなさいと
で アットバー長老が来たら
お母さんが料理作ってあげることを置いておいて
あなたは一人もうそこであんたに見えますかね？家にある財産は
と これぐらい これぐらい
これぐらいあるんだよと
これ全部なくなりますよと
だからこんなこの腐ったものを食べたりとかね
そんなことしなくてもいいんじゃないですかと
ガヤガヤ言うんです そしたらお母さん負けちゃって
奥さんたちに言うんですね
お前らもうあいつをなんとかして誘惑しなさいと
で 誘惑は後なんですけど
お母さんに怒ったんで
長老が あのね 何か食べ物をくれるならばください
でなきゃ私は帰りますと
だから息子がそういう風に言っちゃうと
親にはね 黙っていられませんだから一応食事をあげたんです
それ終わったら説法しなくちゃいけないんで
その時奥さんたちが来て
あれやこれや身振り手振り
いろんなもう誘惑しようと
いろんなことをするんですね
アッタバー長老にはお化粧を塗っていて
あれもうメス猿たちにしか見えないんですね
何やってるのかとね 顔を隠して
あれはもういっぱい体にいろんなものを塗ったりして
アクセサリーいっぱいつけたりして
おかしくてたまらんですね
もう首飾り 腕飾り あれやこれやとかね
足飾りとかね そんなものはアホなら愚か者だったらそれに惹かれますよと
しかし 知恵のある人はそんなもの惹かれませんよと
あの罠をかけて餌を入れても
賢い動物は餌だけ取って逃げていくんだと
罠にかからないで そのように私はご飯だけ食べて帰りますということになったんです
で まあ阿羅漢になっていたんだからね
お釈迦様はそれを知って安全だから行かせたんで
それからですね 王様に会ったのは
はい 3番目は父さんの財産 4
番目 親戚が亡くなるという財産
はい たくさん親戚に囲まれて生活していた人の親戚が亡くなって
一人ぼっちになる 誰もいない私に再起生活はできないと思う
その人は出家する ラッタパーラ長老には
この村にたくさん親戚が親戚がいるのにも関わらず
なぜ出家したんですかと
それで日本でもそれあるんですよ
家族みんなもうなんとか地震とか自然災害で死んじゃうちゃうと一人だけ残ると
もう生活できんですよ
もう家にいられないんですね
ものすごい嫌な気持ちになるんです
それだったら あの悲しみ
全部忘れきれ さっぱり忘れて
修行に運んでみる 励んでみるぞっていうことに出家するんです
だからインドでもそうやって親戚
親族が亡くなったら出家するんです
それにしても あなたの場合はもうもの村
全部あなた方のものでしょうと
親族でしょうねと なんであなた出家したんですか？と尋ねるんです
ということで 出家とは昔からも失敗した人
不幸な人 在宅生活できない人が隠れ場だと思っていたんです
人が隠れる場だと だから現代人だけじゃないんですよ
このコラビ王様も思っていたのは
あれ 出家するのは失敗した人々が
社会で生活できない人々は逃げる逃げ場
その人々は逃げるんだと
しかし ラッタカーラさんにはそういう条件一つも揃ってない
10つの条件 条件といったら災難
だから災難に遭遇した人が出家するんであるという昔の考えなんですよ
だから昔インドでもあの聖なる道で真理を探し求めて出家したっていうのはね
俺お釈迦様だけですよ
それお釈迦様だけですよ
あのインドのヒンドゥー宗教では
あのブラフマジャーリ
グリハスタ ワーナプラスト
サンニャーシという人生は 4つに分けてますよ
一ブラフマチャーリーっていうのはもう子供の頃
勉強する時間で 若くなるまで結婚しない
それから勉強終わって年になったら 2番目の時期に入ります
グリハスト 妻子生活する
それで妻子生活して 仕事をして
子供まで作って 子供もそれなりに独立することになったなってから
ワーナッパスで隠居生活になると
隠居するといったっても
あんまり家にいない どこかに道場かどこかに入ってそちらにいると
それは時期終わったらサンニャーシン旅人になる
人生の最後 いろんなところ
宗教の世界を訪ねて歩くと
だからあんまり真面目なことじゃないでしょ
そういうプログラムだから
だから出家する連中はみんなもうもう年取って追いこぼれなんですよ
結局はヒンドゥ教にしたっても
若者が出家するとはありえないんです
だから今もこのいろんなサードゥという聖職者たちがインドではいくらでもいますよ
見てください インドに行って
よくわかります いかにもう社会で失敗したが
ただ何か金ちょこっと儲かるためにやってるのかと
はっきりしています だからブッダの時代でもそういう考えでしたからね